foreign
Jewel of the West Coast the city of Rose
is a little funky a little weird artsy
one of the best food scenes in the world
that's gone Portland is a hollowed out
shell of what it used to be businesses
are fleeing and people are leaving for
greener pastures if you make over 250
000 you're one of the most heavily taxed
people in the country
for what I mean I think people are
looking around and wondering what
services they're getting in return when
they see lawlessness crime and Decay
Public Safety is failing in Multnomah
County and that's not a shocking
statement it's a complete disaster
2022 set a new record for homicides in
the city of Portland record homicides
for a second year straight record year
of gun violence 96 homicides in Portland
last year and police already telling us
they've responded to 12 shootings in the
New Year homicides up 61 percent a man
dead after a stabbing at a home in the
lunch neighborhood one person dead and
one hurt the walls of her home are
covered in bullet holes police have been
in a standoff carjacked a passing driver
the fourth time in the past year that
the business has been broken into
my name is Kevin Barton and my job title
is district attorney for Washington
County I think it's a true statement to
say that we are seeing increased rates
of crime throughout the state each area
has different challenges but what we're
seeing in the metro area is absolutely
Rising crime
[Music]
so what's happening is with our
decarceration and elimination of bail
culture we've got all these people
running around we've got people pushing
toddlers a woman pushing a toddler onto
the max tracks many of us saw that video
that was not too long ago
someone's in their his 70s his his head
was chewed down to his scalp his ear was
ingested the person who did this was
allegedly on drugs so we have a real
crisis on our hands and a intersection
of homelessness
and crime and then of course this
failure to prosecute and it's really
scary because we also have this
anti-police culture you say you support
the police should I think you'll get the
middle finger pretty quickly
how are people suggesting that we
address homicides if not with police
Portland area is made up of three big
counties the biggest counties in the
state Multnomah county is the biggest
and there's Washington County and
Clackamas County we make up the
Tri-County Portland area the greater
Portland area Washington county is a
large County it's the second most
populous County in Oregon property crime
has increased violent crime has
increased but I should say the increases
that we're seeing are nothing like the
increases that we're seeing in our
neighbors Multnomah County so we are
still a very very safe County in fact we
are the safest large County in Oregon
thank you
I'm John Wentworth on the Clackamas
County district attorney as I sit here
in
have this interview there's a homeless
Camp right outside of my my window
and and that's unique this has never
happened before
um and an increase in organized retail
crime we see that we've seen an increase
in domestic violence
it really took off in my opinion
probably in the last three years the
rise in crime is more moderated in
Clackamas County than I would say it's
it is in uh say Multnomah County that's
a community that has a great deal of
crime two years ago they had the highest
homicide rate
Portland did that it ever had not just
the rate but the raw numbers largest
number of homicides ever and they topped
that last year
we had five
part of it is the the population and
what they expect from their their local
government
part of it is uh efforts to defund the
police which has worked I mean the the
number of police officers at the
Portland Police Bureau has just
plummeted which makes actually
investigating crime challenging
what's frustrating is I hear this from
the from a couple different cities you
know 9-1-1 calls and non-emergency calls
have dropped therefore there's less
crime I would say that's not true what's
happening is people are less likely to
call because you can't get a hold of
anybody or if you call this as we're not
going to go there eyewitness a smash and
grab uh this summer uh in Portland
Oregon and I happen to be standing right
there when it happened and filmed it so
not only did I witness the person I have
it on tape and then I chased them for
about a mile I called 9-1-1 and they
said we're not going to pursue I did
everything and they said we're not going
to pursue that sends the wrong message
why do you think the criminals are out
there doing this because they know even
if a person calls the police the police
aren't going to show and I wouldn't say
it's the police fault because I'm a
strong believer in public safety and I
love working with the police it's their
hands are tied because of politics if a
cop knows it's not going to be
prosecuted why are they going to waste
their time on two hours of paperwork and
drive them down just to go release an
hour later it's a waste of time for
everybody cities that are softer on
crime of course crime is going to go
through the roof
and Clackamas County does things
differently and we our policies are
different than what you would see in
Multnomah County so I'm proud to say
that our police are fully funded in
Clackamas County we've made sure that
it's the number one budget item from our
general budget is to make sure that our
sheriffs and our deputies are fully
funded
we have a strong message and that is
that the mission of Public Safety is
keeping people safe and so that means
that your car should be there when you
get back to it if you park it somewhere
with its catalytic converter your home
should not be burglarized your children
should be safe at school and when you
walk down the street you should feel
safe
[Music]
if you commit a crime you will be held
accountable for that because that will
dissuade people from committing crime
and those who do commit crime will be
dealt with and incarcerated if that's
the appropriate answer or Rehabilitation
will be promoted for them if that's the
appropriate answer
our crime rate is about 30 percent below
the state average and it's about 50
percent below Multnomah County
foreign
[Music]
70 to 80 percent of the cases that we
see the quality of investigation that we
get tends to be good and and allows us
to actually do our part of the job to
ensure that when a victim reports crime
something happens as a result
thank you
so if you were to only look at for
example theft charges in Washington
County for misdemeanor theft charges
which is basically someone stealing
something that's worth less than a
thousand dollars so think of shoplifting
at a Target or a small business or a
Home Depot we file about 91 of those
cases so nine out of every 10 of those
cases that comes in the front door gets
prosecuted and over 90 of those cases
result in convictions those prosecution
rates aren't the same from County to
County and I think has created some
challenges for for counties that have
lower prosecution rights
foreign
[Music]
we can't let anything slip I don't see
graffiti and see the beauty of
independent expression I see vandalism I
see a crime I see a business owner or
the public that has to address and and
pay for the repair that has to be done
because of the graffiti
that's philosophical
but with local policies that are done
the right way with a little bit of tough
love and not enabling this Behavior will
have vastly different outcomes than the
neighboring city right next door to them
you can walk
down your street and feel safe that you
can go down the store your kid can ride
the bike in the neighborhood where you
live and feel safe that your kids can go
on the swing sets and not have to worry
about falling onto someone's dirty
needles
Portland is our largest city in our
state Portland needs to succeed and if
Portland succeeds the rest of the state
succeeds so we all have a vested
interest in making that happen what we
know is that businesses are leaving
Portland people are leaving Portland and
visitors aren't coming to Portland that
needs to stop immediately and it starts
with leadership at all levels it's not
just one individual person or one
individual office but it's all levels of
leadership need to exist to say enough
is enough and this needs to be a safe
City that prioritizes letting people
live their lives in safety
people that are leaving or the people
that are for all the social programs
that that the far left is waving goodbye
to I don't know who they think is going
to be funding all that stuff because
they certainly are not we're committed
to the principles and values that made
Oregon one of the most beautiful and
wonderful states in the union and it's
worth saving voters need to wake up and
vote differently we need people to look
at the outcomes and say that these
leaders make this worse or better for me
is my life better today than it was
this is my home
and I'm committed to Bringing Oregon
back
[Music]